(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Seven miles
off Estonia's west coast
in eastern Europe lies
the small island of Kihnu,
a bucolic and serene place
that feels lost in time.
Home to just 400 people,
it functions like one
of the world's few matriarchal societies.
This is a place where women
rule, well, mostly everything.
Hello, welcome to Kihnu Island.
- [Narrator] One such
tradition is that Kihnu's men
spend months away at sea
fishing for the island.
Meanwhile, Kihnu's women
are in charge of leading
the community and
preserving its way of life.
She is making skirts because
she has five granddaughters.
- [Narrator] The clothes,
the music, the dancing,
all of it has been recognized by UNESCO
on its Intangible Cultural Heritage list.
- [Narrator] The same list
acknowledges Kihnu's women
as the custodians of
their island's heritage.